acquired in january in a blockbuster 14
trade
laverta's 48 days removed from surgery
after his physical found a mass on his
left kidney
the fifth year pro tonight wears the
blue and gold for the first time
and is in the starting lineup as the
pacers visit the red hot suns
basketball as we take a look at curious
lavert because he steps on the floor for
you know the first game in a long time
but when you think about what phoenix
was able to do they got chris paul
and they played well last year in the
bubble but getting chris paul again
they've
done a pretty good job of taking care of
the basketball and coming down the other
way
is levert who was able to draw the foul
five turnovers now for phoenix three for
the pacers
look at it this pacer team very streaky
uh because of their defense they don't
relent
they're gonna keep over playing they're
gonna take chances
and they're gonna force the sons to
maybe be in a hurry and
when players over playing you and
they're being frenetic
that's when you slow down even more you
don't speed up because